[Music]
check
hey welcome back to the explain the
explainer zone
oh i like it you like the explainer zone
i think we that should be what we call
it now the explainer zone
the explainer zone it's like the
twilight zone except
when you leave you know what's going on
that's right the zone there's like the
red zone the end zone
the twilight zone the okay
yeah all right all right i like it the
explainer zone we'll work on that
so i got one for you how about acoustic
effects
in climactic phenomenon
really yeah yeah i i just thought just
thought about that
okay it sounds um like something that
if somebody said to me at a cocktail
party i'd be like i gotta get a drink
i'll be right back
but they will come back because it's
intriguing enough but they gotta get
they gotta pray
but first they gotta get prepped they're
chemically prepped for it
it's that all right so let's let's start
out with um thunder and lightning
for example so lightning
in its path between the ground and the
clouds or between a cloud and the cloud
never goes in a straight line because
it's finding the path of least
resistance
the entire time unknown to you this is
what it's doing and then when you see
the lightning strike
it is already a predetermined path
between one point and another all right
now
it turns out the sound of lightning is
simply the shock
wave of rapidly heated air
by the bolt of electricity
moving through the air which is
extremely hot right
okay it's thousands of degrees but what
matters
is that it is the air is some other
temperature and then it is
instantaneously made extremely hot
this creates an expanding shock wave
that we
hear as thunder okay
now because the because the path of the
lightning
is not straight there are kinks
in the root so each
segment of that kinky lightning
has its own generated
shockwave okay right so now you have
multiple kinks generating their shock
waves
and you can have constructive and
destructive interference
of competing shockwaves that
makes so much sense
oh go ahead okay okay oh this is good
okay so our researcher just found the
the lightning 50 000 degrees 2000
degrees fahrenheit yes yes okay
that that's hot okay all right so now
watch
so with these different segments that's
why
a single lightning bolt and by the way
the lightning bolt is not all the same
distance from you
okay the parts that are a little closer
that are on the ground if it's cloud to
cloud
the part directly above you is closer
than farther away so the
sound will hit you at different times
but it's
one generated event right so
so that's why the lightning can go
okay that's why it's not just one
acoustic experience
it is a it is a highly i love your
thunder i
okay you like my thunder we have to
isolate
i don't know what just happened you if i
see that on a meme i'm going to come
kick you oh my god i am so i'm going
that is so going to be a meme
so so here's the lightning and it's
because
of the acoustical configuration of the
lightning bolt itself
that is wonderful i'm serious that is so
great
because one of my favorite things in the
world
is to hear lightning i'm to hear thunder
but not the rumbling thunder
the thunder that sounds as if it is
tearing the sky
yeah because that it's okay i'm getting
there that's my next point okay
so so that so i'm just simply accounting
for oh by the way
constructive and destructive
interference if you're not familiar with
that
so so sound travels in waves so it
crests and troughs
and that's this is a pressure wave
through the air it hits your eardrum
your eardrum vibrates
we interpret that as sound so does your
body too by the way there are certain
frequencies of sound
that are longer sorry there's certain
wavelengths
of sound that are longer than what will
fit in your eardrum
so your eardrum will have a hard time
communicating it to your brain
but the length of the wavelength is
about the size of your chest cavity
that's the low frequency long wavelength
and so there are some sounds that you
feel more than you hear
that's the rhythm section of this
if i heard lightning starting to do that
it was like whoa there is a god
and god is a dj so
here's what happens the the lightning
sound
is a huge cacophony of frequencies
of sound energy okay high frequency low
frequency
but here's the problem high frequency
doesn't travel very far it's easily
disrupted it's easily
it can easily lose its energy relative
to the energy that it started with
and if high frequency sound loses its
energy it becomes
lower frequency sounds so the
farther away you are from a lightning
strike
the lower is the total cacophony
of frequencies that reach you
so lightning on the horizon is
[Music]
right okay if you have a pet dog they'll
they'll
they hear that and they notice that and
they might start trembling and you don't
even know why
because that frequency is below what you
can hear the dogs hear it all right
as the storm gets closer and closer the
higher frequencies become more and more
part of what you
what you hear and if you hear a
lightning strike
where that sounds like it's ripping the
fabric of the space-time continuum
it meant it hits your house
[Laughter]
all right so so that's what's that's
what's going on
there sound moves through air at about
700 miles an hour plus or minus depends
on the
the density of the air but i like easy
math so let's just
declare that the sound is moving at 600
miles an hour
okay 600 miles an hour is the speed of
sound in air
how far does sound go in a minute
oh that's 600 divided by 60. so how far
i don't know you can
set up the verbal math problem
[Laughter]
i don't know 120 miles
[Laughter]
so if it's 600 miles an hour and you
divide by
60 minutes right okay
then sound will move 10 miles 10 miles
10 miles in a minute in a minute okay
so sound moves 10 miles in a minute how
many seconds does it take the sound to
move
one mile um
10 seconds or six six seconds right six
seconds so it moves a mile every six
seconds so that
after a minute it moves it moves
10 miles and after an hour it moves
600 miles right so so basically
if you want to know how far away the
rain is from you
time get the time difference between
when you
see a lightning strike and when you hear
it so you see the flash and then you
count
one two count one mississippi two seven
three so if it's
five seconds let's say that's almost six
seconds so the storm's about a mile away
mile away
yeah about a mile away and so
and the real number is 700 miles an hour
so it's
you know you make a small adjustment but
you get the basic idea
okay sound moves a mile every six
seconds and so just
for your habits if and if you hear the
thunder and it never gets closer than
that
the rain is not headed towards you don't
worry about it go home go back to sleep
but
if if that time delay keeps getting
shorter and shorter and shorter watch
out
watch out yeah yeah one last house hit
you you're about to lose your house
yeah dorothy you're not in kansas
anymore there you go
nice so a couple of other acoustic
things so for example
a snowflake is very very it's highly
variegated right it's got six sides
it's got a lot of texture and if you
have snow that's descending
and it's just softly landing on blankets
on a surface okay now you have sound
generally when you hear someone from a
distance you are relying on the fact
that the sound is bouncing off the
pavement
off the walls we don't think often about
this
but reflected sound is a big part of how
we
interact with our world around us all
right
if you have snow everywhere the surface
of the snow is not rigid
it's not highly reflective in fact it's
highly absorbent
so particularly for city people know
this
if all of a sudden the city gets quiet
and you don't hear anything look out the
window chances are it's snowing
nice because the sound of the cars and
all the normal sounds that reach you by
reflecting off of
steel and glass and concrete and cement
is no longer reflecting it's all muffled
yeah
and so so the song the christmas song
silent night holy night whatever other
reasons you want to think of it as a
silent night if it has just snowed
guaranteed to be more silent than it
otherwise would have ever been snow it's
nature
soundproofing nature soundproofing now
when you're walking on snow okay
as opposed to walking on sunshine okay
so it's just snowed and you're walking
on it okay
and that will normally be a silent
uh exercise okay because you're just
pressing down
snowflakes because they landed softly
and now you're just sort of compressing
them
fine if it's colder i forgot the
temperatures if it's colder than like
25 degrees 20 low 20s
if it's definitely if it's in the teens
or lower
if you then step on the snow
okay the snow says i will not
yield under your boot print i'm going to
hold my shape
because it is cold enough that we are
all solid and rigid and what happens
the snow crunches yes
then you crunch on snow so if you're
filming a movie or if you're observing a
scene and you hear people crunching on
the snow
guaranteed the temperatures in the low
20s are in the teens
or there's a guy in a booth with some
corn flakes and he's just matching the
sound to the people walking
i forgot the sound studios have all
those sound effects in there
right so so that's why snow crunches at
cold temperatures and does not crunch at
warmer temperatures by the way
at the warmer temperatures your pressure
is enough to melt the snow
okay to bring it immediately below the
freezing point that's a whole other
star talk explainer that we've done what
what ice will do under pressure
under pressure yeah so these are
interesting sort of sound
things to look out for um when this
happens
now it has been rumored that aurora
that you can hear aurora and and i don't
i'm not convinced of that really yeah
yeah because it happens that you know
it's it happens
50 000 feet up you know 10 miles away
and
farther up in the atmosphere where the
atmosphere is really thin
right it is electrical so it could be
that it's it's creating other electrical
phenomena
in your environment but to say that you
heard sound that comes from that high
i'm not convinced of that i don't
believe but people say it so it's worth
investigating
it sings yeah yeah yeah it's worth
investigating
i think so yeah yeah and so let me think
any other sounds you've heard in weather
that you
wonder about i mean you know aside from
the fact that uh
my uncle used to like to make his own
sounds and then blame it on me
[Laughter]
while we were walking in the cold other
than that
now and here's another one um you know
the sound of hail hitting
right these are basically these are like
marbles falling out of the sky
i know what that sound is that is the
sound of a call to the insurance
adjustment yes
so people think you know you know when
do you get hail most you get it in the
summertime
right that's weird ice falling out of
the sky in the summertime
well it's a reminder that the sun is not
heating the air
the air is transparent to sunlight
that's why you can
see the sun from earth's surface through
the air
in los angeles los angeles and beijing
and mexico city right so
those are inversion layers that so
they're climactically susceptible
to trapping smog both those three areas
you notice they're all in basins
santiago chile as well so here's what
happens the sun heats the ground the
ground heats the air
all right but if you go high above the
ground it gets very very cold very very
quickly
no matter the time of year all right but
in the summertime you have the most
ground heating
and so you have the most unstable air
columns
so the biggest thickest juiciest
cumulonimbus clouds which you all
learned about in elementary school
the big puffy ones though you find those
in the summertime
and you look at them and you think the
cloud is just sitting there but if you
look for long enough you will see
that it is roiling and in the roiling
there is
very highly unstable air rising
within it the more unstable the
air is in the upwardly rising columns
the harder it is for whatever is hanging
out in there to fall out of the cloud
wow because it's kept buoyant by these
upwardly moving
air columns so so you
so you first nucleate a little droplet
of of
ice it wants to fall out i say no you're
not and it comes back out and it
nucleates with more moisture because
what is a cloud
it's a big pocket of moisture okay so
droplets
water drops so it gathers more moisture
and ah no you're not and it keeps doing
this
it keeps doing this until the frozen
ball says
you ain't holding me this time
and that's why all of hail is about the
same size
because they had to it had to get to
that size to overcome
the highly unstable air columns that
were supporting
supporting it and so so so the the more
turbulent is the air
the the louder they will be when they
hit the ground and then there it is
and we always reference the size of hail
to
some other object which i find
interesting no one says it was soft ball
sized hair
it was baseball sized hail i've never
seen anybody
talk about um hail sized golf balls
right maybe it's obvious why but i don't
know but anyhow so
chuck that's a little bit of the sound
of weather
i love it so so very cool oh and one
other thing
one last thing you ever been driving a
car and it's raining and
it's raining you know the whole time
you're driving yeah then you come under
an overpass
and it's silent yes okay just silent
that's an interesting phenomenon because
what your brain had done
was create the sound of rain as the
normal
so that when you go under the underpass
it's the absence of rain
that you take notice of see and that
happens in my everyday life
where the normal sound is a houseful
running around when you step out the
house you say what was that
when you step out into silence you
wonder you look around so silent out
here
oh my god did we move to the country
so there's a word i've seen and it
hasn't caught on but i think it should
it's the sound of the absence of rain
under an overpass okay and it's called
a down pause oh instead of a downpour
yeah a down pause
down pause there you go that's lovely i
will leave you with that
a little bit of what weather sounds like
on star talk explainer the
explainer zone thank you chuck ah it's a
pleasure always good to have you
uh we're out neil degrasse tyson keep
looking up
[Music]
you